et parce qu'elle serait médecins
généralistes parce qu'elle sourit
bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur arte france alors conformément
à l' annonce de emmanuel macron la
vaccination s'ouvre dès aujourd'hui à
une nouvelle tranche de la population
une bonne nouvelle même si toutes les
personnes âgées de plus de 75 ans n'ont
pas encore été vaccinés selon vous
bonjour alors tout d'abord je voudrais
bien signalé que je suis affidés d'aucun
syndicat ni parti politique ni de
laboratoires pharmaceutiques et que je
vous je vous parle en tant que médecin
de terrain alors c'est sûr que
l'ouverture de la vaccination au plus
grand nombre est très intéressant c'est
le plus important
le seul souci c'est que on nous donne
pas les moyens c'est à dire qu'on a eu
des annonces de la part du président
comme quoi il fallait vacciner le jour
la nuit les week-ends le problème c'est
que nous avons aucune de mes commandes
de vaccins de lundi 22 mars ne seront
honorés que le 5 ou le 6 avril et
j'aurais que dix doses dans ces
conditions on peut pas vacciner les gens
le deuxième problème c'est que on
vaccine les personnes de plus de 70 ans
potentiellement à risque de faire un peu
vite grave le problème c'est très dur
dit les derniers journaux mondiaux ce
sont des jeunes qui rentrent en
réanimation et c'est les jeunes actifs
qui est diffuse le virus justement
combien de patients de plus de 70 ans
comptez-vous actuellement sur vos listes
d'attentes alors sur les listes
d'attentes j'ai je n'ai que les gens qui
veulent se faire vacciner j'en ai vu
plus d'une cinquantaine
une cinquantaine de personnes qui
veulent aujourd'hui recevoir le vaccin
on a appris également que alors vous en
tant que médecin vous pouvez administrer
le sérum il ya également les pharmaciens
ou bien les centres de vaccination est
ce que finalement aujourd'hui on nous
laisse un petit peu le choix de choisir
notre notre vaccin puisque les personnes
qui sont âgés de 70 à 74 ans peuvent le
faire
on n'est pas véritablement en position
de choisir le vaccin puisque lorsque
vous allez au centre de vaccination
vous aurez le vaccin qui est disponible
et en fonction de votre âge et vos
courbes édité et de vos risques de santé
pour avoir soit le cas et ce lorsque
soit 2 modern à soual astrazeneca en
cabinet et chez le pharmacien salle
astrazeneca uniquement pour l'instant
nous n'avons pas de possibilité de vous
fournir sur un autre vaccin alors vous
avez pointé du doigt cette pénurie de
vaccins auquel vous vous faites face
puisque vous n'aurez pas de vaccin avant
quelques jours
est ce que finalement c'est un effet
d'annonce de la part
des manuels mâcon d'ouvrir la
vaccination plus de 70 ans pour faire un
petit peu oublier le fiasco qui est
actuellement cette campagne c'est un
effet d'annoncé total
pour moi il ya des mots des mots il ya
aucun acte derrière il ya que des effets
d'annoncé
on va voir on va faire il faut mais sur
le terrain on est totalement démunis
vous observez la même pénurie chevaux
collègues médecins c'est toute la france
on est tous en contact via les réseaux
sociaux on a tous le même sentiment
d'avoir été complètement trompé on nous
a promis plein de choses et on obtient
absolument rien concrètement en france
il ya soixante mille médecins
généralistes libéré pour installer si on
nous donne les moyens on peut vacciner à
très haute vitesse
on peut vacciner dix personnes par heure
c'est tout à fait possible
qu'est ce que vous attendez aujourd'hui
de la part du gouvernement c'est que
c'est toute l'europe justement qui qui
pâtit un petit peu de ces retards
dans la réception des vaccins pour moi
moi je demande vraiment beaucoup plus de
transparence
quel vaccin on a lesquels sont en stock
lesquels vont nous arriver et pas nous
faire des annonces en disant vous
demandez vous les aurez dans trois ou
quatre semaines
la deuxième chose qui me paraît très
important c'est qu'il faut ouvrir la
vaccination plus grand nombre on voit
les derniers jours on a vu
l'augmentation du nombre des enfants et
des jeunes adultes en terminer il faut
vacciner les gens qui songent hector de
l'infection et qui participent à
l'augmentation de l'épidémie jacques
think les personnages et pour protéger
l'hôpital c'est très bien tant qu'on ne
freinera pas la circulation depuis
russes n'auront pas de résultat à long
terme
on a appris également récemment que
voilà vous vous demandez à ce que tout
le monde puisse avoir accès aux vaccins
et les plus jeunes certaines personnes
qui n'entrent pas justement dans l'écrit
terme dans les tranches d'âge ont quand
même réussi à se faire vacciner
on parle de gaspillage parfois il ya
certaines doses qui partent à la
poubelle
est-ce que vous en avez eu l'écho voilà
auprès de vos collègues vous même
concrètement il ya énormément de faits
que nous sur ce sujet que des gens
passent à travers les mailles du filet
et se fassent vacciner alors qu'ils ne
rentrent pas dans les critères c'est une
chose pour moi toute dose injectée est
une dose précieuse et je n'ai jamais
constaté que ce soit en centre de
vaccination bailleurs de doses jeter il
ya toujours quelqu'un couponing pour
recevoir une peine maximale merci
beaucoup en tout cas pascal serait
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes médecin
généraliste